if only we were good we'd be socialist
which is a belief that I think almost
everybody has regardless of whether the
columns will socialist or not I'm Rob
not the freezing TV and I'm here today
with Georgetown professor of philosophy
Jason Brennan and we're here to talk
about his new book why not capitalism
every college freshman in this country
within one week of taking their first
political theory class has said as if
they're the first person to ever think
it poor socialism is the best in theory
of course if we were able to scrub out
some of the bugs of humans programming
that's precisely the kind of society
that we'd want to set up for each other
and your book is a direct attack upon
that very particular idea the debate
that I'm having here with with this
Marxist philosopher Jerry Cohen he
basically wants to avoid talking about
what do we do in light of human failure
what do we do in the fed light effect
that people are badly motivated that
they're selfish that they're mean that
they'll often use power for their own
ends he says there's a question about
what's the best response to that but
that's whatever the answer is that's
we're not talking about justice here
we're talking about what we do in the
real world full of unjust people he
retreats to the moral high ground he
retreats back to that idea that if only
we were good we'd be socialists which is
a belief that I think almost everybody
has regardless of whether the columns
will socialist or not they'll imagine a
kind of socialist utopia in which we're
all kind of working together
collectively on projects and we're all
very happy to do that and we share with
one another and we're generous and
that's wonderful and there's no reason
to be against that and in a capitalist
system we would have that kind of thing
- people live in collectives I'm a
capitalist but I live in a commune my
house is a communitive Lee the thing
that I think socialists are often
missing is that we are not the Borg from
Star Trek we have private lives we want
privacy as well we want to engage in
private pursuits like projects of our
own undertaking that we do by ourselves
not with others and so I'd like to say
to my socialist colleagues is if you can
understand why you wouldn't want to say
write a philosophy paper with the
collective you'd rather write a
philosophy paper by yourself or if you'd
like to understand why if you can
understand why you'd like to paint a
painting by yourself rather than having
it done collectively as a group project
you can understand why someone might
find a kind of meaning in
running a business by himself or having
a factory or having a farm that's his
rather than a collective farm so ideally
what you'd want is a system in which
it's possible to realize multiple
different kinds of utopian existences
all at the same time so for you given
your personal dispositions given your
preferences it might be that your idea
of like the perfect society would be one
which is kind of a small fishing village
where everyone knows each other
personally for me it might be something
more like a large city in which with a
lot of advanced technology for some
other person it might be kind of an
Israeli kibbutz and for someone else it
might be a small sort of budva town
where people are buying and trading and
selling and doing mercantile activity
and there's no reason to think that any
one of these visions of how the world
could go is going to be best for every
single person so ideally what you want
is a system under which you can realize
all these different conceptions of the
good life and different conceptions of a
good community a secondary critique as
well that you make about the notion of
socialist utopia and it's this idea that
goes by the technical term the
information problem can you explain what
that is in order for us to have
cooperation on a massive scale
cooperation on a scale of millions or
tens of millions we need some sort of
signal that tells us what's going on in
the economy it turns out in economics we
get that signal in market societies and
it's in the form of prices I think of
like a coca-cola say using aluminum cans
it might be that somewhere on the other
side of the world there's a disaster in
the mine and then it's a little bit
harder to mine aluminium and the price
of aluminium will go up a little bit
because people compete to buy it and
then it comes to coca-cola and they say
well aluminium is a little more
expensive we don't even know why but
we'll just switch over to using plastic
bottles and use less aluminium and then
the price will change as a result of
that and we're all making all these
private decisions and it modifies prices
a little bit and then we respond
appropriately we don't know what's
causing scarcity we don't know what
other people's desires our demands are
we can just see that the price of
strawberries is cheap over here and it's
expensive over here and that tells me
everything I need to know is the
consumer about what to do with the
strawberries in order to best satisfy
other people's needs the problem with
massive socialism socialism a mass scale
is that they don't have a substitute for
prices so socialist planners have to
basically guess and that's why that's
why socialism on the Mount large scale
never ends up working because the
socialist planners literally don't have
the information
they need to make rational economic
decisions and I think that's really
important because in Washington DC I do
not think that there is a cabal of
closeted socialists that want to bring
about a marxist revolution but there is
a very prevalent particularly among the
elite political punting class like a
kind of light maybe less dangerous
version of the socialist conceit which
is a lot of these pundits have ample
number of Ivy League degrees and they
hang around a lot of other smart people
and they begin to operate under the
assumption that it's just a matter of
putting a couple key super intelligent
people in charge and they'd be able to
see everything hack it all and figure
out how to readjust like you know the
economic infrastructure of America in
principle there are cases where an
omni-benevolent omniscient dictator
could come in and fix the market and
make it better in principle that's the
case it's rarely going to be the case in
actuality that a person knows when and
how to intervene to improve it so given
the limits of human knowledge given the
limits of people's ability and also just
given their biases and so on and the
fact that they're likely to use this
power selfishly rather than for own our
own good
I think it's better not to empower them
to do these things you debunked this
idea that sort of capitalism capitalist
social technology engenders or
cultivates certain vices that it
actually actively rewards greed and
predatory behavior wide range of people
like Herbert dentists and Paul Zak and
Joseph Henrich and a number of other
economists who and social anthropologist
and others who study what markets do to
people
one thing that they'll do is they'll
have to say plate take games like
there's this game called the ultimatum
game where it gives me the opportunity
to cheat you and they'll have people
play this game from all over the world
and then see what factors determine
whether people play honestly or
dishonestly what they find is the
biggest cultural predictor that you will
be trusting trustworthy generous fair
and so on is the extent to which you
come from a market-oriented society
people from traditional societies from
tribal societies from kind of non
pre-market societies and from socialist
societies are not nice the idea that I
think that people of our political
persuasion don't as actively engage with
I would like is this idea that there is
an arbitrary distribution of attributes
and advantages at birth and by genetics
and by environment and someone with
maybe more progressive politics someone
who's a bit more friendly to the notion
of government intrusion oftentimes
that's based in an authentic and
good-hearted desire to correct for those
particular kind of arbitrary
distributions of advantages you know I'm
not really concerned about a quality in
an opportunity for its own sake society
is not a race we know one has to win
it's a it's a cooperative venture for
mutual gain so in a race it's very
important that everybody start in the
same position because the purpose of a
race is to measure relative performance
and relative talent that's not what
society is about it's just us
cooperating with one another so I think
here the question isn't can we actually
have equal opportunity but rather should
we have a political system or economic
system that tends to make sure that
people have more opportunity rather than
less and then everybody have sufficient
opportunity what I end up doing in the
book is saying that the capitalist
utopia that I described the supposed to
be juxtaposed and compared to ensuring
to be superior to the socialist utopia
that Jerry Cohen describes it endorses
principles of social justice and enjoy
endorses principles of beneficence but
the way that they achieve these goals is
not through a kind of heavy-handed
government intervention but through
private means
[Music]